A firing squad
chief of
Russia's private army, Evgeny
Prigozhin, saying he's certain
there will be major Russian losses
on the battlefield in Ukraine
and the loss of territory inside Russia.
And Prigozhin predicts
that those losses will be so significant,
the firing squads will be ordered
to execute the generals
responsible for Russian failures
across a popular revolt
that will rise up over
the military's mistakes.
Schedules made by Syria.
You upset with me?
With the Mujahidin,
we will now suffer serious losses
I am absolutely certain of it.
Now we are certainly losing
some Russian territory.
This part being in the Russian Federation
would prevent
there will either be a popular revolt
or the State Duma will make a decision
for capital punishment
and given them the down.
And by the way, I can tell you honestly,
I think we're two to three months away
from the firing squads.
This comes
as Ukrainians are making gains
around the key city of Berkeley.
And Sam Kiley is OUTFRONT
Ukraine's third
assault brigade is in action
near Barmouth.
And they claim they're making advances
around the city,
but their attack is dependent
on soviet-era weapons.
Modern equipment from the US and NATO
is apparently being held in reserve
for a Ukrainian offensive.
Do you have a name for your grant?
So what's offensive
Is it good enough for this fight?
The start and I
look at the list of choice.
Some of you saw
Ukraine gets no help at all
with aircraft.
Not so far.
This SOVIET-ERA helicopter is ancient,
but in combat.
Almost every day
flying dangerously low to avoid missiles
and russian jet hunter killers
civil liberties are about to
start somewhere,
but keep you mostly with. No, no.
Uh, you do say,
uh, non-nuclear thought.
The one if principle
that was an idea was in it.
These aircraft
will fly more sorties
as fighting intensifies
in a relentless cycle of war.
Ukraine has now got added rage
at what it's calling a Russian ecocide.
This part of Kherson has suffered
Russian bombardment
across the river for months now, near
total destruction from up river
Russia is widely
blamed for the collapse of the dam
at Novakovic,
which has been under its control
since March last year.
Civilians who survived
the Russian occupation of their town
and an offensive to free it
are now facing down a new horror.
Thousands have no drinking water here
a drone delivers help,
an adaptation of a system
originally designed not to save life,
but to take it
now.
And these recent successes
that the Ukrainians are claiming
may well be in part as a consequence
of effectively mutinous behavior by Mr.
Prigozhin, who
just the other day captured
the commander
of the 72nd mechanized brigade,
a Russian brigade,
the neighboring unit
to Wagner in Vermont, beat him up,
forced him into
an online confession
in which
he was told to say that he'd been drunk
and opened
fire on Wagner
troops It's just that kind of collapse of
law and order
within the Russian ranks
that the Ukrainians
be absolutely delighted by
if you couldn't,
if that didn't exist,
I think the Ukrainians
would have wanted to make him up.
Erin?
Yeah, I mean, it it it is unbelievable.
It defies belief.
All right.
Thank you very much, Sam
reporting live from Kiev tonight.
And let's go now to the former U.S.
ambassador to Russia, John Sullivan.
And Ambassador Sullivan.
I'm so glad to have you back.
So, you know,
Sam is talking about the Russians.
Do they have control of that dam?
In fact,
they have had control of that dam
for months.
And now they haven't provided
a single shred of evidence,
but they are keeping up a narrative
that it is Ukraine's fault.
This does seem absurd.
It seems to defy credulity, does it?
Absolutely, Erin.
And you hit the nail on the head.
They're in control of this dam
because they invaded
Ukraine in February of 20, 22.
This war would end.
There would be no dam collapse
if the Russians hadn't invaded Ukraine.
It's ultimately Russia's fault.
So you obviously saw Putin.
You knew him up
close as ambassador to Russia.
So better than anyone.
You have a sense of how he operates, how
he thinks.
You've got a counteroffensive now,
seemingly in full swing.
You have attacks on Russian territory.
You've got Prigozhin
saying all sorts of things.
What is Putin's mindset like right now?
As best as you can imagine?
Well, I think from his background
in his training,
going all the way back to his KGB days,
he would never show it.
The more difficult it gets,
the cooler and calmer he
will try to appear.
But he is under enormous stress.
Now, Erin, there's
there's no doubt about that.
Secretary Blinken recited in a speech
last week in Helsinki
how this war has been a strategic
catastrophe for Putin and Russia.
And day by day,
whether it's the dam collapse,
whether it's Prigozhin, the head of
as you accurately described it, Putin's
private army,
talking about senior
Russian generals being executed.
This is calamitous for Russia
and for Putin.
And let's talk more about what
Prigozhin said. Right.
He predicted those firing squads
in Russia
within two to three months,
which would target Russia's top generals,
Putin's generals.
He also suggested Putin might detonate
a nuclear weapon in Russia, in Belgorod.
I don't know
whether it's a false flag or what,
but he said that
he's claimed to take a Russian commander,
a top Russian commander hostage
as a P.O.W..
I mean, this seems to be reaching
some sort of a breaking pit
breaking point, even for someone
who's actions and words
have frankly been been
quite shocking for a long time.
They have been there.
And it's just
it's it's a a growing cascade
of crazy statements by Prigozhin.
I mean, months ago,
he was calling the minister of defense
and the chairman
of the Russian general staff
cowards and traitors
and their children, cowards and trains.
And it's just been a further escalation.
Every time he speaks,
there's something more outrageous
that he says in part to get attention.
But the important thing to note, Erin,
is how dependent Putin is on him now.
You described in the opening
of this segment, this is Putin.
This is his private army,
the success they had in Bermuda.
The Russian government itself,
just a couple of weeks ago,
a tribute attributed that success,
at least in part to Wagner.
So it's dependent
on those soldiers that Prigozhin leads.
So amazing.
All right.
Thank you very much, Ambassador Sullivan.
I appreciate your time as always.
Thanks, Erin.
And next, former vice.